Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J’ai cinq ans, là, cinq ans.
Si je ne m’exprime pas bien, dites-vous
que c’est parce que j’ai cinq ans.
Je ne suis pas très loin d’ici, dans le
Bourbonnais, à Saint-Bonnet-de-Rochefort,
dans le salon de mes grands-parents
qui habitent là.
C'est un salon, comme tous les salons.
C’est-à-dire qu’en face de moi,
il y a une cheminée.
À droite, il y a une table,
à gauche, un canapé.
Mais ce qui m’intéresse, moi le petit
garçon que je suis à cette époque-là,
ce n’est pas la cheminée,
ni la table, ce n’est pas le canapé,
ce sont les murs.
Parce que les murs, ils ont l'air vivants.
C’est impressionnant,
il faut vous imaginer :
chaque pan de mur est recouvert
de ces drôles d’objets en cuir
ou cartonnés qu’on appelle des livres.
À l’époque, je ne sais pas lire, mais je
sais déjà que ce sont des objets vivants.
D’ailleurs, les murs semblent vivants.
Un livre, ça a une texture
quand on le touche.
Un livre, ça a un parfum très particulier.
Un livre surtout - et ça, c’est quelque
chose qui me frappe beaucoup -
ça a un goût.
parce que j’ai déjà vu
ma mère et ma grand-mère,
pour tourner une page,
mouiller leur doigt.
Il faut que ça ait un goût pour
qu’elles mouillent leur doigt.
Alors je suis là, tout petit,
haut comme trois pommes,
devant ces murs bibliothèques.
Ce que je fais, c’est que je me mets
sur la pointe des pieds
pour en saisir un, que je fais
glisser des murs bibliothèques.
Je le prends dans mes mains.
Je l’ouvre.
Je l’ai pris au hasard, je le ressens,
je le touche, je le caresse.
Puis j’entends derrière moi quelqu’un
qui entre - c’est comme une effraction.
Le livre est tombé.
Mon grand-père vient juste de rentrer.
Je le vois se pencher -
c’est mon plus vieux souvenir.
J’ai cinq ans et je le vois se pencher
pour prendre le livre
et pour me le tendre.
Sa main droite, ma main droite,
un livre entre nous deux,
un livre qui nous sépare.
C'est mon plus vieux souvenir.
Je remarque tout de suite -
je ne sais pas lire -
que le livre ne s’est pas cassé.
C’est un livre -
Et donc, dans ma petite tête d’enfant,
je me dis qu’un livre,
ça résiste, c’est dur, c’est fort.
Ce que je remarque aussi,
dans le geste de mon grand-père,
c’est qu’un livre, ça se passe,
ça se transmet, ça crée une sorte de lien.
Je ne sais pas lire à l’époque,
mais je me souviens d’avoir fait une
promesse à mon grand-père à ce moment-là.
Une promesse comme on en fait quand
on a 5 ans, c’est-à-dire très solennelle,
je lui ai promis de lire
tous les livres du monde.
Grosse promesse.
On ne va pas se mentir, aujourd’hui, cette
promesse, je ne l’ai pas tenue du tout.
En revanche, j’ai toujours gardé
cette idée, ou plutôt cette intuition,
qu’un livre, c’est d’abord une reliure,
c’est-à-dire quelque chose
qui assemble des pages,
des idées, des histoires, des récits,
les fait tenir ensemble,
les fait tenir debout.
Mais c’est aussi une reliure, un livre,
parce que ça relie les gens,
en fait, tout simplement,
ça les met ensemble.
Cut 2018.
J'ai 38 ans et les livres en fait,
je leur ai dédié ma vie.
C’est-à-dire que j’ai fait
des longues études de littérature,
j’ai été prof de littérature,
j’ai tenu des émissions
de radio et de télévision,
j’ai parlé de culture,
mais surtout de littérature.
J’ai toujours dit partout
dans les salles de classe, les studios
de radio, les plateaux télé,
qu’un livre, ça changeait le monde.
Comme un mantra, comme ça.
J’en avais l’intuition -
depuis mes cinq ans, je vous ai raconté -
mais, entre nous,
je n’en avais pas la preuve.
Eh bien, cette année-là, en 2018,
j’ai fait une rencontre
qui m'en a apporté la preuve.
J’ai rencontré un homme qui s’appelle
Patrick Weil, qui est un grand historien,
et qui m’a invité à participer
à une association,
une ONG qu’il a créée à l’époque,
dix ans auparavant,
et qui s’appelle
Bibliothèques sans frontières.
La mission de Bibliothèques
sans frontières est très claire :
favoriser l’accès à l’éducation,
à l’information et à la culture
auprès des plus vulnérables.
Patrick Weil, je ne le connais pas.
Je lui dis : « Patrick,
évidemment, j’aimerais bien.
Tout le monde a envie de faire ça.
Mais si c’est pour faire un post
Instagram ou Twitter le soir du gala,
merci, mais non merci.
Je préfère - pas folle la guêpe -
puisque vous êtes en France
et dans une cinquantaine de pays,
vous suivre, aller avec vous sur vos
programmes dans le monde entier. »
Je dis ça avec panache, comme un défi.
Lui me regarde très calmement,
il prend le temps et il me dit :
« OK, on part la semaine prochaine,
en Sicile,
où on a installé une bibliothèque
dans un centre d’accueil de réfugiés. »
À ce moment-là, j’ai une grande curiosité.
Je me dis :
« Dans un centre d’accueil de réfugiés,
on a besoin des choses primaires :
de quoi se nourrir, de quoi se loger,
des trucs pour la santé.
Mais des livres, c’est audacieux. »
J’y vais avec beaucoup de curiosité.
Je suis parti une petite semaine avec lui,
avec Bibliothèques sans Frontières.
C’est le premier programme
que j’ai visité.
Et en fait, ça a tout changé.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai 43 ans.
Des programmes de Bibliothèques
sans frontières, depuis presque 5 ans,
j’en ai visité plus d’une trentaine.
Je suis parti à Marseille,
dans les quartiers Nord.
On a installé des bibliothèques
au pied des immeubles,
mais aussi au Burundi,
dans la banlieue de Bujumbura.
Je suis parti dans des camps de réfugiés
en Jordanie ou au Bangladesh,
mais aussi en Colombie,
où on a créé des bibliothèques de la paix
dans le cadre de la réconciliation entre
les ex-FARC et les populations locales.
Un souvenir de là-bas : quand je rentre,
il y a une petite malle où on vous dit :
« Prière de mettre
votre pistolet dans la malle. »
C’est vous dire l’enjeu
de cette bibliothèque.
Je me souviens d’autres programmes,
et notamment
de ces gymnases d’hiver réquisitionnés
par la mairie de Paris pour les sans-abri,
où on en a installé.
Ou de ces lavomatic aux États-Unis
où on a mis des bibliothèques aussi
car on s’est rendu compte que
c’était le lieu de sociabilité privilégié
pour les noirs américains
les plus précaires,
ils y passent le plus de temps.
On a mis des bibliothèques ; c’est
un programme qui s’appelle Wash and learn,
qui cartonne, qui fonctionne,
qui est efficace.
Je pense aux centres d’accueil
de réfugiés en France et en Pologne,
à la frontière ukrainienne.
Je pense à toutes ces micro-bibliothèques.
Il y en a quinze en ce moment en France.
L’année prochaine, il y en aura 30,
dans dix ans, mille.
Ce sont des petites bibliothèques
que vous, moi, tout le monde peut créer,
avec l’aide de
Bibliothèques sans frontières,
dans votre quartier, votre territoire.
Il suffit de remplir un appel à projet -
c’est très rapide -
et de demander une donation de 1500livres
de Bibliothèques sans frontières.
Si vous avez la même intuition que nous,
qui est une conviction en fait,
qu’un livre, ça peut tout changer
parce que ça crée du lien et un lien
qui dure longtemps, très longtemps.
Il y aurait mille exemples à prendre.
Je voudrais en prendre
trois très rapidement.
Mayotte, quartiers prioritaires.
On a un programme qui me touche
énormément, appelé Entre générations.
De façon très simple,
Bibliothèques sans Frontières
propose à des jeunes
d’interviewer, d’interroger leurs aînés,
des personnes âgées,
qui vivent dans le même territoire,
pour leur parler de leur vie,
de leur territoire, de leur quartier,
mais aussi de ce sentiment d’appartenir
à une même communauté.
Très concrètement,
la bibliothèque crée un lien entre
les jeunes et les personnes âgées.
Deuxième exemple Bujumbura,
au Burundi, quartier de Buterere.
On a un programme magnifique
avec les enfants des rues.
Il s’agit de les rescolariser.
C’est un programme assez passionnant
pour Bibliothèques sans frontières
parce que quand je l’ai visité,
je me suis rendu compte tout de suite
qu’on n’arrivait pas
avec un projet français,
avec le Petit Prince en disant :
« Lisez-le, c’est formidable. »
Pas du tout.
Vous travaillez avec une association
locale dans la langue locale, le kirundi,
et surtout avec des médiateurs locaux,
des gens qui, pour certains - c’est
l’avantage d’une ONG qui a 10, 15 ans -
ont été bénéficiaires
eux-mêmes de l’association,
et, en l’occurrence,
ont été des enfants des rues.
Ce sont eux qui vont voir les enfants
pour les emmener
à la bibliothèque pour les rescolariser.
Très concrètement, ils créent
du lien avec la bibliothèque.
Troisième exemple : Bangladesh,
Cox’s Bazar, le camp de Kutupalong,
le plus grand camp de réfugiés
au monde - 1 million de personnes.
Des réfugiés, deux tiers sont des enfants.
Là-bas, les médiateurs
de Bibliothèques sans frontières
travaillent avec des réfugiés
rohingyas, mais pas seulement.
Ils travaillent aussi avec les populations
bangladaises qui vivent alentour.
Parce qu’en fait, ces populations,
les Rohingyas et les Bangladais,
culturellement, ils sont très proches,
bien plus que ce qu’on
veut nous faire croire,
beaucoup plus que ce que des frontières
artificielles créées par l’Homme
veulent bien nous faire croire.
Et concrètement, au sein de la
bibliothèque, on crée du lien.
Un dernier exemple qui me bouleverse
et qui me vient à l’esprit maintenant.
Je suis très ému quand je parle
de Bibliothèques sans frontières.
Ça concerne la lecture
et ça concerne l’illettrisme.
On parle de situations d’illettrisme,
car l’illettrisme, ce n’est pas
une destinée, ni une fatalité.
On peut toujours s’en sortir.
La France est le pays d’Europe occidentale
qui a le plus haut taux d’illettrisme.
C'est un problème.
C’est une raison pour laquelle
la lecture était grande cause nationale.
Bibliothèque sans frontières répond
à ce problème depuis des années,
avec des programmes formidables
en France et dans le monde.
Je pense à un programme qu’on a dans
le nord de la France, à Aulnoye-Aymeries,
avec une association locale
qui s’appelle Mots et Merveilles.
Ce jour-là, quand je vais visiter
Mots et Merveilles et notre bibliothèque,
qui est une bibliothèque mouvante
comme toutes nos bibliothèques,
Je me souviens, un homme arrive,
à peu près mon âge - j’ai 40 ans.
Il est avec sa petite fille de six ans.
Il me dit : « Je vous la laisse,
moi, je ne viens pas.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce que c’est une bibliothèque.
Je n’y vais pas, moi !
- Ben si, quand même. Pourquoi ?
- Parce que je ne sais pas lire.
Donc les bibliothèques, je n’y vais pas. »
C'est intéressant.
Ça veut dire que la bibliothèque,
elle est associée à un capital.
C’est un mot qui fait peur,
associé à des vieux fantômes
de l’Éducation nationale.
C’est un ancien prof qui vous le dit.
Mais je peux vous dire
qu’il y est entré parce que là-bas,
le mot « bibliothèque »,
comme « livre », « culture »,
ce ne sont pas des mots qui font peur.
Ce sont des mots qu’on s’attache
à désacraliser, justement.
Les livres, là-bas,
on les ouvre, on les manipule,
on les corne, on les déchire,
on fait des arbres
avec des feuilles de papier.
On les fait tomber, on les ramasse,
on échange, on apprend à lire, on joue,
on est ensemble.
Et là, quand je vous parle,
je n’ai pas 43 ans comme aujourd’hui,
je n’ai pas 40 ans à Aulnoye-Aymeries,
j’ai cinq ans,
je ne suis pas très loin d’ici,
dans le Bourbonnais, dans le salon
de mes grands-parents.
Mon grand-père vient juste -
vous vous souvenez ? -
de se baisser pour ramasser le livre
que j’ai fait tomber et il me le tend.
Un livre nous sépare,
mais en réalité, ce livre,
c’est tout ce qui nous relie.
Et pour longtemps.
À l’époque, je ne sais pas lire.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a dedans.
Je ne connais même pas le titre
de ce livre, je ne peux pas le lire.
Je ne sais pas que ce livre,
par exemple, il a 2500 ans.
Pas le livre, mais le texte
en l'occurrence.
Je ne sais pas qu’il raconte justement
l’idée d’un sentiment d’appartenance
à une communauté
et que c’est quelque chose qui se réalise
par la grâce d’un texte, d’un chant,
d’une histoire, d’un récit, d'un livre.
Je ne sais pas que
quarante ans plus tard,
je serai devant vous,
parce que c’est ce livre-là.
C'est l'Iliade d'Homère.
2500 ans.
Je ne sais pas si, dans 2500 ans,
on aura toujours Internet, par exemple.
Internet qui est censé nous relier tous,
si ça se trouve, ça aura sauté.
Si ça se trouve, on nous l’aura enlevé,
on n’en aura plus les moyens.
Mais quelque chose me dit que ce livre-là,
alors corné, raturé, élimé,
tout ce que vous voulez,
mais d’une façon ou d’une autre,
il sera toujours là
car il se sera disséminé dans tous les
textes qui auront été écrits par la suite.
Parce qu’on se le sera raconté,
parce qu’on se le sera passé,
parce qu’on le lira.
D’une façon ou d’une autre,
il continuera à nous relier.
Merci de m’avoir écouté.
(Applaudissements)